erstmal vielleicht die gute Nachricht
wir sind nicht Pleite es werden auch
keine Regierungsbehörden schließen wie
in Amerika aber in der aktuellen Notlage
braucht es womöglich erstmal einen
großen feuerlöscheer und der hieße
Schulden machen um die weggebrochenen
Schulden auszugleichen Deutschland kann
sich das leisten der Schuldenstand ist
im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern noch
vergleichsweise niedrig vielleicht wegen
der Schuldenbremse und dann
Schuldenbremse aufheben höhere Steuern
mehr sparen schon möglich dass der Druck
des karlsraur was genau dazu führt dass
die Ampel sich auf beides einigt das
muss nicht so schlecht sein eine höhere
Erbschaftssteuer oder eine
Vermögenssteuer z.B oder sparen bei
bestimmten subvenstionen wie dem
Dienstwagenprivileg aber reichen wird
das vermutlich
[Musik]
nicht